so Whole Foods is known for being
expensive known as whole paycheck by
some people
Whole Foods was purchased by Amazon in a
major deal over the summer for 13.7
billion dollars and they officially
closed the deal earlier this week on
Monday and there have been a bunch of
articles written saying major price cuts
at Whole Foods by up to 43 percent
Wow that is huge right well they did cut
prices by 43 percent on organic Fuji
apples from 349 a pound to $1.99 a pound
you'll actually see if you're watching
with us a list of some of the products
where prices were cut they range from 7%
to 38 or even 43 percent like the Fuji
apples organic avocados or $1.99 rather
than 279 now down 29% there's a big list
here right so what's the strategy Amazon
for a long time has been a total market
share business they would reportedly buy
electronics at full price from
manufacturers to then sell them on
Amazon for the exact same price or at a
slight discount all to take up market
share and it's pretty likely that that's
going to be the same strategy at Whole
Foods you cut prices on some or many
grocery items you get people in the door
you continue to take market share from
other grocery stores and grocery store
chains and the value for Amazon is not
in eking out every last penny of revenue
from eggs it's the real estate it's the
brick-and-mortar stores it's the urban
footprint and the Millennial and high
income customers and as well as the
distribution network right Whole Foods
can tie into Amazon fresh they can tie
into Amazon pantry and Amazon Prime they
can use whole food stores to test that
Amazon go system they did that in
Seattle it's like a cashier free grocery
store where I believe it's through RFID
technology the store can tell what
products you've put in your basket and
then you just walk out and it's
automatically charged to your payment
method on file and the bigger market
share can may
get so that Whole Foods can
simultaneously try to become known not
so much for high prices but maybe for
the best technology or whatever the case
might be that'll probably pick off some
market share from people who otherwise
would go to Trader Joe's or a local
grocery store or somewhere else as well
as help to push forward the market share
rather the technological advancement
plans of Amazon more broadly and there
are people who are really angry about
this I was reading articles about this
online pad and there are people who
based on their income they don't care
whether organic avocados cost 279 or 190
199 they don't want whole foods to be
more crowded
they don't want less wealthy people
showing up people are genuinely angry
that Whole Foods has reduced prices on
some items well that certainly sounds a
bit elitist to me I mean this whole
thing or this purchase of Whole Foods by
Amazon I can see how it's polarizing
because on one hand there's this concern
of corporate consolidation yet on the
other hand you're interested in the
innovation of things like Amazon go
being brought to Whole Foods sure but
with this specifically I'm just a little
bit indifferent it just seems like a lot
of the grocery store items are going on
sale and this is you know something that
already plays into their whole business
structure as it is well I guess the idea
is that these are not so much sales as
Whole Foods is now permanently reducing
the price of some staple items and hey
that's right right I'll be there
reducing prices that that's perfectly
fine however not only do you have
concerns about the corporate
consolidation we've seen others like
Walmart for example undercut prices in a
way that really kills the local
businesses grocery by definition is an
area where margins are really really
slim and this is a move that not only
could a grow market share for Amazon
slash Whole Foods because of the fact
that they're lowering prices it could
also grow market share because it could
drive competitors out of business
further fueling this cycle of
consolidation so I'm both very
interested in this because these are by
and large two pretty innovative
companies Amazon and Whole Foods but at
the same time I have major concerns from
an economic inequality
and and and sort of monopoly standpoint
about what the future holds here would
you go to Whole Foods would you be more
likely to go to Whole Foods because
avocados dropped by 80 cents Oh
naturally yeah I think I think if the
goods are cheaper I'll be more inclined
to go there but also if there's this
small organic foods co-op in the area I
would be more inclined to visit there
because it just seems like you know
something that affects my community a
lot more even if it's more closer to
home even if it's more expensive yeah I
mean that's something you have to weigh
right Wow Wow all right well Pat bull
Pat we'll go to the local grocer that's
a reason why you don't go to Walmart
isn't it
yeah that's true I don't go to Walmart
for a long list of reasons